- 5-Minute Crafts made
five of my veins pop out
of my head the last time I watched it.
Let's see if they've
improved this time around.
Peewoop!
Headache from reading a
book. Maybe you need gla...
Okay. My God, they go
into the 3D effects of it.
What are they show-
Blood. Lots of blood. Neurons.
Okay. Nerve endings are activa...
Can you imagine my patient
walked in with a headache
and I'm just like, "I got you."
Well, I don't even have
any hair right now.
(TV beeps)
See, I love it
that they don't make any claims.
That's how they get away with it.
You assume it's a headache.
It says nerve fibers activating,
which is kind of true.
Anytime you touch yourself or move,
nerve fibers are activating.
And then she smiles, and you
think the headache is gone.
But they never said
that she had a headache.
We're the ones interpreting
their art wrong.
Suffering from heartburn?
She gonna roll over to the other side,
and they're gonna say that's
the better side to sleep on.
- [Sam] We'll see.
(intense music)
- Three years undergrad,
four years medical school,
three years residency, five
years practicing medicine.
I could have just done this.
- [Sam] It's gonna change the
way you practice medicine?
- We should just close med schools,
and just tell people to
watch 5-Minute Crafts
'cause apparently it's that simple.
There's legitimate things you
could do to treat acid reflux.
Raise the head of your bed somewhat,
so you stay like this and
gravity will keep the acid down.
Don't eat so close to bedtime,
at least two hours prior.
Don't ingest things that
create more acid secretion,
like caffeine, especially at bedtime.
See, these are things that actually work
that we tell our patients,
not random things like
rotate to the other side
and that prevents gastric juice.
Yeah, what about if you
have a hiatal hernia?
Look that one up.
Ooh, those blisters are brutal.
Second skin. That's the way to go.
(Mike laughs)
That hit me unexpected!
I was like, "What kind of tape is that?"
And then bacon just pops up on top.
Oh my God.
Can you imagine the fungus
that's gonna grow on that?
Can you imagine you're at work
and there's just bacon
falling off behind you?
People are gonna have questions.
And it was a hot summer
day 'cause of the friction.
Maybe you cook it. Maybe you eat it.
- [Sam] Mm. Little lunch.
- That's the joke.
That's the joke in there.
Get some second skin. It's inexpensive.
Basically, it decreases
friction on the area.
It falls off after a few days.
You could shower with it.
All that good stuff.
Mom is asking the child
where he got this pill from.
Maybe that's not what's happening.
(Sam and Mike laugh)
(TV beeps)
He doesn't want it.
He had a marshmallow.
We got an Exacto knife here.
Mom's performing surgery.
She sticks a pill into the gummy bear.
You need to be careful
with stuff like this
because some medications you can't chew
and you must swallow whole.
So if you give your
child that pill in there
and your child chews it,
that could be a big problem.
No, Q-tips in the ears!
Also, what kind of ear wax is that?
It's some powdery ear wax.
Hydrogen perox- Oh, okay.
Wow. I'm touched. That was a good video.
You don't have to do it like that.
There's drops that you
could put in your ears
that contain hydrogen
peroxide, like Debrox drops.
You gotta make sure
that you don't have any
other issues going on
when you are using that.
It basically melts the wax
so it comes out nicely
out of your ear canal.
I like it. Decent advice.
What is this high-end swing
and where do these high-end swings exist?
That looks nice. Braided, high-end.
Oof. Nice. Look at that wood. Fresh wood.
Mommy, don't stop.
How about mommy puts away
her TikTok for a second
and pays attention to her child?
I knew she was gonna create
some ridiculous thing.
The purpose of you
standing next to your child
is not just for you to
do this back and forth,
but it's to bond with your
child, to have fun in the moment.
And you know what? To be
there in case the child falls.
What are you gonna do when you pull
it a little bit too hard
the child falls backwards?
Okay, kid getting pushed around
in a little Ferrari truck.
Save the drama for your llama.
10 out of 10 for the cute poster.
Oh, you know what happens when
you get back pain. Quidditch.
There is no way that you said grab a stick
to push your child around
in a car as a real hack.
She couldn't use her foot?
And I like the kid's Bulls hat.
It looks like the Bulls hat I came
to the United States
when I was a little kid.
Okay, there's a fake doctor
with a really fake medical
background behind them.
And there's a microscope-
Plastic microscope on
the desk. And a Band-Aid.
Oh, child doesn't want a Band-Aid,
but we're gonna draw hearts on it.
Wow. That's design hacks right there.
Wow. Look at those designs.
High quality design.
It's like when girls go to get a manicure,
or guys for that matter,
and they get all those intricate designs.
And they're like, "Yo, check
out my Pikachu nail design."
I'm like, "Yeah, but check
out my Band-Aid with hearts,
5-Minute Crafts edition."
Okay, nervous about a meeting.
Nervous about a meeting.
Very nervous about a meeting.
Brushing your hair
for five minutes helps
you cope with anxiety.
Did they just create an
OCD type coping mechanism?
Potentially, she will no
longer feel comfortable walking
into social settings unless
she's combed her hair.
- [Sam] How else would I do with it?
- Psychology.
- [Sam] Oh.
Is that a service provided
by family medicine doctors?
- And mental health providers worldwide.
Okay, hanging out. Get sand in your eye.
Okay, spill the water bottle into a bowl.
Dip your face in water.
Okay, do they really say that
you get something in your eye,
use water to get it out?
Can you imagine getting mud on their body
and then going to a shower to
wash it off and say, "Hack"?
No, I mean, that's what we just witnessed.
She just poured out the water bottle
that she spent five minutes
spitting into with her bacteria.
- [Sam] Pink eye is gonna happen here.
- Could be bacterial conjunctivitis.
- [Sam] That right.
- And it could be even worse.
She could get a corneal abrasion
which can lead to infection
if there is a lot of bacteria in there.
Look at this dangerous misinformation.
Cute little baby. Baby don't want milk.
Baby wants a watermelon.
This is a medical danger,
and this needs to be corrected ASAP.
You do not put straws into
a watermelon that has seeds
and give it to a child
so they can inhale one
of the seeds and choke.
See, that's cute, right?
But then mom walks away,
and the baby sucks on the opposite straw
and inhales a seed.
Full on choking hazard here.
Good job, 5-Minute Crafts.
Yes, I'm angry.
Okay, child runs up with a Band-Aid.
Upset because she doesn't
want to take it off.
Wet it. Oh, wow. Life hack.
People didn't know
that sticky substances
come off with water.
Wow, I needed a YouTube
video to learn that one
'cause I didn't know tape
was susceptible to water.
It's like a fire Pokemon.
(TV static blares)
Bee. CGI bee.
That's funny. I just said four letters.
And everyone knows what
I'm talking about. CGI bee.
Oh, and it left it's
little stinger in there.
Oh, what do we got here?
Who has that device? Who
has that device on them?
This CGI on this is topnotch.
Okay, mommy's washing hands.
Child is washing hands.
No soap. I guess this is a common issue.
Jelly soap?
Oh, she's gonna make soap
in the shape of LEGOs.
That's kind of cool.
Really cool, actually.
This is the only one I would probably try.
I just don't know how effective it is.
I guess whatever's in that
jelly soap, I hope is good.
Yeah. I'm with it. I like this one.
Okay, they finally got a
Dr. Mike stamp of approval.
Okay, sleep, little baby.
Sleep, sleep, sleep.
Oh, mom doesn't know how
to take off a hair tie.
Oh, she's gonna put lemon.
What is she gonna do
with the essential oil?
Why did she put essen...
What kind of chemicals did she just put
on her child's hair
that ate through rubber?
And why was she unable
to just take them off?
Who is gonna go and purchase that product,
and then when their child falls asleep,
sneak into the room and
start applying chemicals
to their children's hair?
Want some water. Child doesn't want water.
Says, "Ew," to the water.
Let's put some lemon in the water.
Chewy candy and olive oil?
Whipped cream? Sprinkles?
Again with tiny inhalable objects.
Why are they trying to kill children?
Maybe those are a little bit
too big to go into the straw.
But still, why even risk it?
Especially if they start
melting and they get smaller.
Yeah, if you put lemon in water,
it makes lemon water
and it becomes tastier.
You didn't need all the other stuff.
Okay, mom's washing hands. Child runs in.
Also wants to wash hands.
Good teaching opportunity
to sing "Happy Birthday"
while you foamy up your hands.
We're gonna put soap. The bugs
will be pushed away from it.
But see, the soap shouldn't go in there.
It should go on her hand.
If anything, you could
get one of those kits,
they're relatively inexpensive,
where you put all this stuff on your hands
and then you shine a light on it.
And you see the stuff
is all over your hands.
And then unless you wash very thoroughly,
you don't get it all off.
That's a better teaching experiment
than whatever's happening here.
Okay, some blackheads,
AKA closed comedones.
Floss. No, no, no. This is
a bad trick. Don't do this.
Oh, what? What the heck is happening?
Is that a hot glue gun?
- [Sam] Give it a chance.
- Okay, what are we doing here?
We're creating a
flossing kit.
Their hack for blackheads
is to 3D print a handheld nose flosser?
And rip your skin off?
Wash your face. Wash your
face. Wash your face.
Dark armpits?
Dark armpits can be caused
by a condition known as type two diabetes.
So maybe you should go see your doctor
and not make a lemon
flower juice potion for it.
There's hormonal conditions
that cause darkening of your armpits.
Maybe you should
legitimately see your doctor
and give that recommendation,
5-Minute Crafts,
'cause you could just have hidden
their actual medical condition.
Milk your feet.
This is for the foot fetish
people. That's who watch this.
A slow pouring of the
honey across the feet
with the massage piece.
Look, if you're into this, cool.
But medically, it's not that serious.
Yeah, right. I buy that.
FTC. Can we get in here
on this? Ridiculous.
Blackheads? Lemon. Again
with the concoctions.
Dude, they just pour random stuff
that are labeled healthy into dishes
and then act like it helps.
Like seaweed. Why is seaweed going in?
No, no, that's not gonna work.
Dry skin? Same person.
It's 'cause you put the seaweed
on your skin with the green tea.
Mixing the petals. It's
a very pretty concoction.
It's a honey petal.
So arbitrary.
Check out my video of
everything that went wrong
when I went on tour.
It actually shows some bits of the show.
Very funny. Worth a watch. Bear's in it.
As always, stay happy and healthy
unlike those 5-Minute Crafts.
(upbeat music)